it is great to welcome John Perkins back
to the program he's an activist and also
author of the classic
book Confessions of an economic hitman
more recently the author of touching the
Jaguar which is available now John great
to have you back it's wonderful to be
with you again David thank you I love
you to show you the great stuff so I
appreciate being on your show thank you
thank you well listen I wanted there's
so many things I want to ask you about
one is from your perspective if
coronavirus has served as a sort of way
to test the economic system that we have
which you know so much about and have
have critiqued in so many interesting
ways over the years what has coronavirus
exposed about the underlying reality of
our economic system well you know to
answer that I just a little story here
that a number of years ago I took a
group of people you know I take people
to the shamans of Latin America on trips
and we were with a lady shaman high in
the Andes of Ecuador Quechua speaking
shaman with a wonderful name of Maria
Juana Maria Juana yeah young Bella and I
was translating someone asked hey Maria
Juana
how do we save the earth and she laughed
and she said you know the earth isn't in
danger but we are and a bunch of other
species we take with us then she pointed
up with this huge sacred volcano that
lives near her house that hovers over
her house sorry it was our house called
in by border and she said a few years
ago 20 years ago that that volcano was
covered with a massive ice cap it isn't
anymore
mother earth is is twitching we're like
so many fleas if we get to be too much
of a nuisance she'll just shake us all
off and she's twitching up she's showing
us the the glaciers are melting and you
know I thought I thought David over the
years every time there's been a major
hurricane or fires and in Australia in
California or whatever and what these
once is 100-year events that happened
every year or so now I remembered what
Maria Juana said but you know that and
that they've been sending us a message
that this death economy doesn't work we
got to create a new system but we've
we've taken
as a local thing so if I survive a
hurricane
I expect outside the outside world to
come to help me bring water food etc the
coronavirus has taught us that there is
no outside world this is global
everybody on the planet is being
impacted and we're seeing you know
people that people can see stars over
over Shanghai in Los Angeles these days
it's having a huge impact with all of
our lives are changing we don't like
change it means don't really like change
but we've all been forced to change
radically and we're coming to understand
that maybe some of those changes are
further better that they actually make
life more interesting more fun so when
you worked as a self-described economic
hitman you were able to essentially I
mean I don't think I'm speaking out of
turn by saying profiting from some of
the underlying fragility of the system
that we have which a lot of people may
not really see as fragile do you agree
that coronavirus has exposed that even
stable seeming economies are actually
far more fragile and in a matter of just
a couple of weeks can fall apart very
quickly
it's absolutely exposed that and it's
also exposed the tremendous inequalities
that that our system is filled with you
know the the racial discrimination the
gender discrimination all all this all
these inequalities are really coming to
the surface so I think the coronavirus
is showing us our shadow side and in
fact the way many governments have
reacted to it has shown us our shadow
side too and shown us that the old
system isn't working we don't want to
return to normal we want to create a new
new normal that's a we call a life
economy and so can you talk a little bit
about as specifically as you want what
those changes would be I mean one of the
fundamental realities of the economy we
have is that being proactive is
fundamentally not encouraged because
proactive just means you're spending
money on stuff you might not actually
need to spend money on essentially right
you're spending money now for something
that may happen but but it may not what
are the changes that would need to be
made in order to
to have what you call a life economy
what some might call a more sort of
human centered capitalism or some other
term that would be applied to it
well yeah David so a great deal of the
book touching the Jaguar centers around
the idea that the truth
that human reality is molded by human
perceptions I learned that when a shaman
saved my life in 1969 deep in the Amazon
but it's also the basis of modern
psychotherapy of quantum physics of
marketing of advertising if corporate
policy our perceptions control our
reality
this death economy what we many
economists are referring to the death
economy because it it's consuming in the
short term the resources upon which it
depends in the long term it's exhausting
and it's destroying the environment as
we know it and it's based on one
perception and that is that businesses
have the goal must have the goal of
maximizing short-term profits for a few
investors really regardless of the
social and environmental cost and that's
taken us down this very very dangerous
road so what we really need to change is
that perception we need to touch that
Jaguar it I'm touching that Jeff all the
time it's the Jaguar that that keeps us
locked in the fear that changes is
dangerous and you know we don't want we
don't want too much change but what we
need to do is change that goal that
perception of that in the goal needs to
be instead of maximizing short-term
profits to maximize long-term benefits
for humans and and the entire in all of
nature part of that I mean that this
critique so you know in the business
cycle
it's about what was your quarterly
profit what did you do for the year what
was earnings per share the political
system is also based around this right
in the sense that if members of Congress
are up for re-election every two years
if the president's up for reelection
every four you're essentially constantly
campaigning and this also at a systemic
level encourages what can you justify
that you did in the last six months
rather than how did you improve the
country for the next twenty or thirty
years
right and that's that's exactly what
needs to change so so let's you know
encourage businesses to invest to pay
investors to invest in things that clean
up pollution that regenerate destroyed
environments that recycle that come up
with new technologies you know we've
gone a long way with wind and solar but
in a way those are both in their infancy
let's move beyond that was let's channel
the air into forms of energy thus
there's so much that we can do and we've
learned how to be creative during this
coronavirus you know for as an example
of over 50% of your tax dollars in mine
if you're an American citizen I go to
the military in the discretionary budget
and and our military is doing some crazy
things like building more aircraft
carriers and missiles and and and things
that the Russians and Chinese are not
focusing on at all they're focusing on
cybernetics and they're focusing on us
technologies imagine if some of that
money that we're currently paying
Raytheon and General Dynamics to use to
build these systems that are basically
obsolete instead we put that money to
encouraging these companies and
entrepreneurs and other companies to
mine all the plastic that's floating
around in the oceans and and all the oil
that's leaked around oil get gas
stations all over the world and in the
oil drilling sites and there's so much
more there's so many many things like
that that we can pay people to do we're
talking about a full employment economy
here we're talking about a life economy
what we're talking about instead of
making those widgets and stuff that you
mentioned earlier that people don't
really need and in a way we probably
don't even really want except we're
given the impression hey if you don't
wear this shirt nobody's gonna want to
date you
[Laughter]
you know this impression there's this
perception that's created our reality we
need to create another reality that what
we really want to invest in are the
things that will make life better for
all of us and for future generations
right I mean my framework as I you know
I don't necessarily need to label
everything but I think an ideology that
pretty well describes my views would be
social democracy which is that the
our areas where I'm fine with the market
directing resources as long as the
market is well-regulated and it's a fair
market and the government as you say is
saying there are some things that are
bigger than profit so for example
cleaning up the oceans may not be
particularly profitable in the way that
we would measure it in the short term
but the long term value of it to humans
is such that that should be taken
outside of the market forces is that
more or less that the ideology are
applying it is David and and I think we
have to look at the definition of what
what's successful statistically the
measurement as you as you pointed out
GDP isn't is a standard measurement tool
and it's a lousy one and I just got that
when I was a an economic hitman that
that I thought that because I was taught
in business school that if you invest a
lot of money in infrastructure and in
poor countries that have resources your
corporations want you use those
resources as collateral that helps
everyone because you can show that when
you do that the GDP grows well they came
to see over time that that's really only
helping the very wealthy people because
GDP is very skewed toward the wealthy so
if you take for example the United
States with three individuals have as
much wealth as half the half the
population of our country if those three
individuals made ten percent and return
on their investment last year and half
the population lost three percent
we're still short growth of GDP of
something a little under five percent so
the measuring-rods that we're using do
not tell us anything about true
prosperity in a country they tell us
about the prosperity of the wealthy the
big businesses and those people who own
those big businesses and so we really
need to change that whole way of how we
look at what's successful and measure
success much more in in the long term
and how it impacts everybody not just
the big owners of big businesses what
are some of the metrics you would
suggest including I recently read the
Charles Wieland's book naked economics
and there's things I like it and things
I disagree with but one of the things he
talks about is
we should at minimum if we want to
evaluate how an economy is doing we we
can include GDP we should look at
unemployment we should look at
inequality we should look at poverty we
should look at trade balance although
individually none of these metrics tells
us everything we need to know they can
start to paint sort of a picture what do
you think of those what would you add
what what would you be looking at well
there's so many things along those lines
I mean we should we should be measuring
the value of somebody doing housework at
home the woman man doing doing housework
taking care of the kids the value of
people making music you know you're in
Boston there's a lot of amazing
musicians in all over New England that
I'm making a living doing it they got to
make a living doing something else and
then in the evenings they go off and
play their music these this is this is a
huge value that same as writers our
artists there's so many things labor
should be should be considered much more
valuable than it's considered labour of
all kinds our health care workers and on
and on and on there's so many measures
one of the most important ones is that
we don't include externality so when an
oil company drills for oil in a country
let's say Ecuador where I was a Peace
Corps volunteer and it's been how large
part of Ecuador's environments been
destroyed by Texaco now Chevron that
they don't have to pay for that that's
not included in the price of oil that
they that they charge they just dump the
waste they don't have to pay for the
cleanups or all the people that suffered
but that's true throughout all the
businesses it's not just the oil
companies there's all these
externalities they should be included in
the cost and when you start including
them you see that that that other things
have a great deal more value is that the
biggest failing of markets if you had to
pick what it is that that they'd really
don't even though efficient market
hypothesis folks tell us that markets do
account for externalities that they
really don't and that's where you need
government to step in yeah any any any
accountant will tell you that the
externalities many of them are not
included at all you know that the people
that are used in sweatshops overseas or
now a lot of its by you know the people
that answer their telephone calls in
other countries
their health is not paid for it's not
taken into account if they get sick they
get fired and yes and that's a lousy
that's a terrible system so so yeah that
certainly is a starting point but I
think the most important thing that we
all need to understand is the basis of
the system the the assumption is based
on this perception that you must
maximize short-term profits regardless
of the social and environmental cost and
this means that a CEO is is actually
given the mandate to do whatever it
takes to maximize profits and that may
mean destroying the environment
destroying the resources upon which his
company depends in the long run in order
to make short run profits it exploiting
labor corrupting politicians and and now
it means you know these companies have
learned how to corrupt politicians
legally because as we all know nobody
gets elected to a big public office in
the United States without huge amounts
of money that basically is generated by
corporations one way or another and and
these people are offered incredible
high-paying jobs as consultants
lobbyists whatever when they when they
leave politics so so we've got this
system where where CEOs are basically
forced by the investors by Wall Street
by their owners to do whatever it takes
to maximize short-term profits and
that's proven to be insanity it's taken
us down this course let's cause so many
problems when you come right down to it
David the coronavirus the racial
discrimination climate change
income inequality extinct species
extinctions those are all problems but
they're not the disease they're not the
problem they're symptoms of the disease
and the disease is in economic it's
really a governmental social economic
system that we can call the death
economy that just plain isn't working
anymore it had worked it gave us amazing
science and medicine and art and so many
things but it's reached its limits it's
time is over it's time to move into a
new system a life economy
the book is touching the Jaguar now
available we've been speaking with the
book's author John Perkins John always
great having you on I so appreciate your
time thank you so much David and I would
just like to point out that the subtitle
of the book is transforming fear into
action to change your life in the world
and yes in the there's a whole process
that people can go through on a daily
basis or a weekly basis for about 10
minutes that guide each individual
whether you're a carpenter or a plumber
or radio show host or a writer like me
that'll take you down this course to
transform your life and and in the world